hey everyone we're gonna be doing
something a little different this week
I've got Maajid Nawaz jumping on a Skype
call shortly
he and Sam Harris are co-authors of a
new book about Islam and Majin is a
former Islamic extremist himself a ton
of you guys have been asking us to sit
down but he lives in London so we
thought we'd give the Skype thing a shot
actually he's in New York at the moment
I saw a picture of him and Morgan
Freeman in a mosque yesterday so I'm
gonna ask him about that and much more
in a little bit but first let's do a
little housekeeping I want to talk about
some of the principles we laid out in
the first episode and some of the
reaction to last week's show it seems
that a bunch of you weren't thrilled
with my guest Jimmy door Jimmy is a
hardcore lefty progressive and uses some
of the tactics I mentioned that I
wouldn't be using on the show first let
me just say that I can only hold myself
to the rules that I laid out if I
stopped and mention signing every time a
guest said saying that goes against my
personal rules the show would be
incredibly slow and horrific ly painful
more importantly as we build a community
based on tolerance and other ideas it's
important that we remain tolerant of
ideas we don't like Jimmy is a great
friend of mine we've worked together on
air for years we've done stand-up gigs
together and I've had him and his wife
over for dinner numerous times yeah we
don't agree on everything including some
pretty big issues but I think life is
about more than just scoring who is
right on everything all the time
the most interesting part of last week's
response was that some people said the
episode was an echo chamber and I didn't
push back enough other people questioned
why I even had people I disagree with on
at all and that's the beauty of the
internet right we can all be part of the
same exact conversation and still see it
through our individual prisms good
journalism is the search for truth this
show will be a battle of ideas not just
having our own ideas reinforced you know
there's so much intolerance of the other
on both sides and I think we can create
something that's so much better than
that actually I don't just think it I
know it because I see it already
happening last week I had a hardcore
progressive lefty this week I have a
former Islamist extremists turned
moderate trying to reform his religion
next week I have a gay conservative from
Breitbart million applets I won't agree
with all of them all the time but I most
likely won't shout them down either I
have enough faith in you guys that if we
have an honest conversation here the
truth will present itself
this of course reminds me of the
Galactic Republic in the
early days of the Deathstar grand moff
tarkin wanted to stifle debate because
they had the most powerful super laser
in the universe of course let's not
forget that Darth Vader said that the
Death Star was nothing compared to the
power of the force the force is on our
side let's use it wisely
all right so magic thanks for doing this
we've been going back and forth for four
months now I've only had the show up for
four three weeks but we've been going
back and forth for a while and you're in
New York right now you live you live in
London correct that's right yeah yeah so
you live in London so you're halfway
between Los Angeles and London so I
figured we do the Skype because I don't
know when you're gonna be out here any
any LA plans coming I don't know I mean
I'd love to come to LA and I love life
good friends in on the west coast but
nothing fixed yet all right it's it's
good to have this opportunity yeah all
right so we'll do the Skype thing with
you in New York me and LA so first off I
saw a picture of you that you tweeted
yesterday you were hanging out with
Morgan Freeman in a mosque so what what
was that about yes this is what's
brought me here to to New York I can't
explain too much of it at the moment all
I can say is that I had a great
conversation with him in the in the
Islamic Center of New York we spent a
good hour also having a chat about the
distinctions between Islam and Islamism
and about my story and the work I do but
beyond that we're just gonna have to
wait and see what I was up to all right
well now he's played God so I guess he's
the right guy to talk to on that in in
the house of God I was speaking to a man
that played God about God all right
there you go okay so I want to talk to
you about some of the things that you
probably did speak with him about so
first let's just start with your story
because you're your biography what
you've lived through to get to here is
really really incredible so can you just
sort of sum that up in a couple minutes
you know those who want the as you know
the full story it's in my memoir called
radical but but in a in a summarized
form basically I joined a revolutionary
Islamist group at the age of 16 years
old I ended up on the leadership of this
organization and spent 13 years with
them and I played my role in exporting
this all as a
from Britain to Pakistan and then to
Denmark and eventually to to Egypt the
group's name was his battalion it was
the first among these limits groups to
popular reaction of resurrecting a
caliphate that would seek to conquer
other countries and enforce their
version of Islam as law and their method
by which they aimed to come to power was
via military coos so we were very much
focused in recruiting army officers to
join our organization and then sighting
them towards military coups and that's
what took me to Pakistan is what
eventually took me to Egypt I arrived
one day before the 9/11 attacks and then
10 months later I found myself arrested
and detained and taken to the torture
dungeons of Egypt's state security
headquarters in Cairo and then sentenced
after four months in solitary
confinement sentenced to five years in
prison as a political prisoner that's at
that point is when Amnesty International
adopted me as a prisoner of conscience
began campaigning for my release because
of course though we had views that I now
find repugnant and what describe his
extreme we were and we and a group still
is non non terrorist which is why it's
still legal in America and among us
across Europe so it's it's the
distinction I draw between an Islamist
group and a jihadist group is that if
Islamism is the desire to impose any
interpretation of Islam over Society
jihadism is the use of force to spread
Islamism and and jihadist terrorism is
the use of force to spread Islamism by
targeting civilians the group that I
joined was an Islamist group it wasn't a
jihadist group right so I'm glad you
made that distinction because I do find
that when we're having this conversation
and it's being had by so many different
people in so many different forums that
just the definitions alone are lost and
I know you've done a lot of work trying
to just explain that kind of stuff to
people so they're able to understand
what we're talking about here you know
positive the problem is because this is
a phenomenon that we've never really
dealt with before in terms of human
beings have never really dealt with this
phenomenon of of ideological Islam
seeking a very Bolshevik form of control
totalitarian control over society we
simply as people didn't have the
lexicon to have these conversations so
though I use these definitions you won't
find these definitions taught in
universities or in academic terms
because people or dealt with a problem
before so part of the challenge that we
faced was in coming up with very crystal
clear logical definitions and then
popularizing them and so you often
you'll find that I repeat myself a lot
and there isn't I repeat myself is
because you know we have to to
popularize these terms and to popularize
these concepts can only come through
repetition until everyone finally begins
to understand and it got to a point
where the premise from the UK understood
yeah we got somewhere okay so you spent
about five years in an Egyptian prison
now that was under Mubarak at the time
who technically I suppose he was known
as the president but he basically was a
dictator that was backed by the US for
about thirty years
what was that like being in an Egyptian
prison I can't imagine well it wasn't a
pleasant experience at all you know we
had the the torture first of all for the
past four days and then we were put into
solitary confinement for four months and
I was held in a Cell as were all of us
in that period of solitary confinement
in cells where in which we had no
sanitation no lights no no beds we had
nothing but a bare concrete cell in
which to in which to try and get through
without without going insane and so I
have with me actually I wanted to show
you this because yeah I had a when I was
arrested I had a pocket-sized version of
the Quran which is this in my hand here
this this particular Quran has been with
me from the day of my rest all the way
through the torture dungeons through the
solitary confinement Wow and then
through through the four years in prison
and and one of the things I did is in
the solitary confinement we didn't have
any any light to read with or anything
so and obviously the mind can wonder in
that sort of situation and you fear for
your own sanity so one of the things I
would do is stand by the by the door of
the of the jail cell let's look for the
wait for the light to seep in through
the bars and then I would stand there
and read if you can see is a very small
the text is actually tiny yeah well and
I would read that I ended up memorizing
half of it I'm struggling in my jail
cell
but it was you know that it was these
sorts of things and it's why I've kept
this it was these sorts of things that
kept me from going mad during the
solitary confinement period and another
thing I want to show you is this this is
um this is a radio which I had with me
is sort of it was given to me by the
British Embassy
and it was actually on this thing that I
heard first time that we'd be charged we
we hadn't been for informed why
officially but the BBC World Service had
reported it and so I was listening to it
on this and we found out there in fact
we've been charged and we would go to
trial and finally I think this picture
is up on the internet but I have the
original with me and this is um
something I stole from prison and I've
kept it with me ever since because it
means a lot to me this is the mug shot
that was taken of me so that that's the
day that's the very day we were dragged
from the torture dungeons to be thrown
into solitary so that's before I was
actually before I was actually put into
solitary confinement that's me at 24
years old and there you see what you see
is my my name in Arabic Majid Rahman
Noah's and there is a prison number and
what I've done of course since then is
I've taken that number which is in
Arabic two four five three and I have
tattooed it on my back as a as a
reminder for me actually of those days
and of where I've come from which was
your original question and the journey I
made to get to where I am now
yeah it's such an incredible journey one
other thing on the jail thing I find
that fascinating that they let you keep
a copy of the Quran with you because
wasn't Mubarak basically not that he was
secular per se but they were you know
the Muslim Brotherhood was illegal under
him you would think that he would want
no sign of religion to get the prisoners
to up rise or something like that and
yeah he let you have it or they on the
contrary on the contrary now I'm not
gonna I'm not about to defend Mubarak I
cheered when he was overthrown that he
was held in the set himself that he held
me and afterwards so I'm not I'm not
here in any way to defend house knee
Mubarak what I would say is that the
Egyptian dictator and his regime already
understood the distinction and that I
now made between his
Islamism their problem wasn't us holding
copies of the Quran their problem was
the interpretation that we spun and the
ideology of Islamism that I referred to
that they would encourage us to study
traditional medieval Islam because they
knew that medieval Islam wasn't Islamism
and they would encourage us to be
exposed to theologians from Azhar
University which we were in prison and
their books so that we could read about
the Sun from its medieval era and
understand it wasn't this modern
ideological forum that we'd come to a
dog now I say this and I say it with a
caveat that of course traditional
ultra-conservative medieval Islam also
needs to be reformed you know it's not
the pinnacle it's not the kind of you
know the the epitome of of civil
liberties however what we what we have
to accept anyone who knows the basic the
basic thing the most basic thing about
Islamic history and the development of
Islamic theology well know for all of
its faults and there are plenty of
faults by the way and you know
fundamentalism largely owes a debt to
sort of the fact that they see Muslims
generally still Revere that medieval
period of our theology and haven't
developed it since but it's still very
different to what the Islamist project
is and and the Egyptian authorities knew
that so they would encourage us you know
they would rather we were are
conservative religious or fundamentalist
Muslims than members of the Muslim
Brotherhood yeah that that's so
fascinating and even if you think about
what's going on with Egypt now where we
sort of have another version of Mubarak
and Sisi and sort of controlling things
and yet you know the Muslim Brotherhood
was in charge for a year and we back
them to but that's a whole other topic
so before we move on to some of the
other stuff I saw a clip where you were
on Real Time with Bill Maher from about
a year ago and on the overtime segment
you recounted a story about a bomb maker
that you met in jail and I was hoping
you could you could just sum that up
real quick because I thought I thought
it was fascinating it it goes yeah very
much what you're talking about right now
yeah sure um so in prison there was a we
were imprisoned with the who's who of
the jadi scene at the time we had the
assassins of the almost Egypt Anwar
Sadat who was killed in 1980
one group was known as Tom Rieman jihad
those who weren't executed in that case
were with us in prison we have a leader
of the Muslim Brotherhood dr. Muhammad
and videos since been reincarnated as
you mentioned he wasn't the leader of
the Brotherhood at the time he since
became the leader of the Brotherhood but
he and his entire leadership were with
me in prison we have the leadership of
his material and we also had people that
came from abroad and the the bomb-maker
that you referred to I he particular was
from Dagestan next door to Chechnya and
they he came via Afghanistan to Egypt in
an attempt to cross that off our
crossing into Gaza to teach Hamas how to
make bombs but he was caught afire by
the Egyptian authorities and they
imprisoned him they sentenced him to 17
years and I became friendly with this
man and had a long conversation with him
due to the the London bombings because
you know the invasion of Iraq happened
when I was in prison and the London the
7/7 attacks in London the bombings and
sort of the buses in the tubes in London
also happened when I was in prison so I
locked it I could have got locked into a
long conversation with this with this
man about the in his view the legitimacy
of attacking London and I was attempting
to convince him that it wasn't
legitimate now again because I used to
belong to a non terrorist yet revolution
so extreme Islamist group we didn't
believe in Jihad this Impa to come to
power so we were arguing with the
jihadists that actually what they should
be focusing on is a military coups and
that's why I was opposing him not
because I hadn't yet left I hadn't yet
left is limited it's because my form of
Islamism in its method had you know was
very different to his in its sort of how
it seeks to come to power sure but one
thing I you know I'm really proud of is
that here's a man who was trained was
fully capable of of making bombs and
causing mayhem and mayhem and havoc so
yeah when I put it to him that the
justification he uses to to say that
it's legitimate to target British
citizens in that they voted for their
government would be the same
justification one could use for Turks
who voted for their government in Turkey
as a member of NATO and NATO as an
alliance was involved in Afghanistan and
so and so why wouldn't he be bombing
Turkey
and and his answer that he be answer he
gave me was a pragmatic one not a
religious one at which point I caught
him out and I said you see so you know
what you're doing is you're playing
politics you're giving me a pragmatic
answer which is a very thing when Bush
does it you criticize Bush for the
upshot of that conversation was by the
end of it you know it took him a couple
of days or whatever he not to my my jail
cell and he came back looking really
sheepish and he said you know I've been
thinking about what you said and I think
you're right and I just don't think we
with you it's it's not justified to
attack British civilians and one of the
things that really swung him was the the
fact that so many in the UK protested
against the Iraq war so my argument to
him was how can you be attacking these
people but I'm happy you know he changed
his mind I don't know where he is or
what he's doing now but that's you know
that's it's a small incremental step
towards peace and reconciliation and it
was one of the first examples that I
felt set me on the path that I'm now on
yeah and that that's why I wanted to ask
me about that because I love the story
it's a beautiful story in it and it's
about what I think your whole life now
is about which is trying to explain all
this to people and actually get people
to change and I think one of the
problems we're really having here is
that I see both sides on this or however
many sides you want to say there are I
see everybody's sort of getting
entrenched and and the dialogue sort of
disappearing so I think that's a perfect
segue you just call authored a book with
Sam Harris I had Sam on the show a
couple weeks ago it's called Islam and
the future of tolerance so first off I
think people would love to know a little
bit more about the nature of your
relationship with Sam how you guys came
together Sam of course is a devout
atheist you're you're a practicing
Muslim correct I don't call myself
religious or didäôt I'm a Muslim but I
wouldn't want to hold myself up as any
form of standard for anyone to judge the
religion by or anything else well there
you go so that said tell me a little bit
about how you got connected with Sam and
what sort of brought you two together to
really go ahead and start doing things
like this
so we Sam and I first met a few years
ago when I came to New York where I am
right now to debate a on heresy alley
and the motion of the debate was Islam
is a religion of peace and there's
something I need to clarify
with that debate hmm is that I've never
believed it say never sorry in my
current incarnation after leaving his
bateria I've not believed that Islam is
a religion of war or peace and this is
something like bending of my dialogue
with Sam I chose the side of that motion
that Islam is a religion of peace
because there was emotion and I had to
choose whether it was a religion of war
or peace and pick aside
I think the emotion was worded
incorrectly frankly um you know I I have
a religion of war nor peace it's just a
religion religions are interpreted but
nevertheless at on the side that it was
a religion of peace because I logically
reasoned in my mind that if the majority
of Muslims today aren't jihadist albeit
many many many Muslims you know I'm not
you know liberal in the way I would like
they're certainly not jihadist
terrorists and so if religion is what
people make it is lamb is what Muslims
interpret it to be then by definition
it's a religion of peace simply because
Muslims by the overwhelming majority are
not terrorists so I sat on that side of
the debate and I debated a on afterwards
we ended up in the dinner afterwards and
and Sam happened to be there and I
haven't met him before and he was called
upon by an to ask me a question and he
asked me you know he said look it's all
good and well you being out there
needing to present this view to the
public about Islam being this or that
but you know here between us in in the
privacy of this of this dinner can't you
just be honest with us and tell us that
you know what you really think about
this line is about religion so I my
video reaction it was to say to him are
you accusing me of lying um what you
mean can I not be honest with you
implying that I wasn't honest outside
there on that you know the platform yeah
and it became a very hostile exchange
which ended there it didn't go any
further and everyone was really
embarrassed around the table we didn't
really develop beyond that at that point
and then we didn't speak for a couple of
years um and and so then Sam reached out
to me when I think um he'd watched me at
the Richmond forum when I was reunited
again where they are this time
the good thing was it wasn't a debate it
was a conversation and that's actually
the Richmond before I want to thank if
the people from the Richmond forum are
watching this I want to thank them
because the format that they got the
say moderator John Donvan to the
moderated the debate at the intelligence
squared exhausting earlier occasion but
instead they got a on myself and Imam
Rolf who had been the the Imam of the
main Manhattan mosque and instead of
having a motion to debate they just said
all of you just want we only had to have
a conversation so that really allowed
for me to be in the middle because he
mazzaroth was arguing Islam as a
religion of peace
I almost arguing it's not that it's a
religion of war instead and it allowed
me in the center to say guys you know
actually ions got something right you've
got something right there's actually
something in the middle here and that's
that I think that conversation really
set the precedent for what happened with
sound and me afterwards because I think
he saw that I think a.m. was really
impressed with that the the tone that I
took with her in that conversation and I
was really happy with the result in the
way which we she reciprocated my
overtures to have and I think that
really the foundations for what happened
next and then Sam reached out to me and
said hey can we kind of have that type
of conversation for my blog um this is
you know he interviews people on his
podcast he publishes it on his blog so I
said well yeah sure and we've sort of
had this some exchange over the phone
and he transcribed it and I said Sam
this is actually really good I don't
think you should put on your blog I
actually sense this is a book that gets
you know that could really influence a
lot of people and so then he approached
our Harvard and thank God the
editor-in-chief of Harvard agreed and
that that's the story of the book which
hits the shelves in a week yeah so so
we'll talk about more about Sam in a
second but I think something interesting
that you said about ion is that so I
think a lot of your critics or a lot of
the people that are critical of everyone
on your your side of this is that that
you guys all think exactly the same
thing but so I'm fascinated that so you
and I on actually don't agree on certain
elements of this well you see that's the
laziness and the knee-jerk reaction the
emotional reaction which is born of fear
the fear of dialogue and the fear of
actually having conversations with
people that we may disagree with is that
actually the best way to ignore the
consequences that dialogue can work is
to tarnish everyone with the same brush
and it's to infact effectively slander
everyone um yeah and that way we are
justifying to ourselves and those who
are listening to us why dialog isn't a
good thing the truth is that um even
after this dialogue with Sam there are
probably many things that he and I don't
see eye-to-eye on and we they are as
well and but the important thing is in
recognizing that dialogue is a process
it's not a union just snap your fingers
and somebody agrees with you um and
democracy itself by the way liberal
democracies weren't born in a day um the
reason why we use the word mature
democracies when we refer to countries
like United States the United Kingdom is
because they've had centuries over over
which time they've matured and that's
what the views that analogy that's
exactly what a dialogue with people you
disagree with is that the matures over
time right so there's been a bunch of
people you can name them if you like
we've talked about them a lot here and
I'm almost I'm almost tired of talking
about them at this point who are writing
some pretty horrific things about you
you know the worst kind of slanderous
stuff calling you names that if anyone
on the right called you they'd be
condemned and and rightfully so and I'm
seeing so much of this coming from the
left and these are the people who I
thought would be the ones standing up
for all the things that you're talking
about here the words that you're talking
about conversation liberalism all of
these things and you're getting it from
the left what do you make about that so
you know let's move away from the
individuals and and and look at the
movement and and you know the
individuals at the end of the day you
know they whatever they say about me and
wherever they are and have used a
certainly one as bad as I was when I was
a revolutionary Islamist so I hope they
can change oh you're a good guy you're a
good way well I believe in change and I
hope that you know people adapt turn to
phase if they do change their views I'd
be perfectly happy to continue being
friends with them reza aslan used to sit
on my organization's board in london as
a member of our advisory council and we
disbanded it two years into founding our
organization so it hasn't existed for
about five years but you know we used to
know the guy we invited him to London
for our for he's spoken at my offices in
London ik William so you know people
change and I'm hoping and I'm hope
you know we can resume of the cordial
form of relationship with all of these
guys and you know I just think that if I
can if I can be go from where I was to
where I am I have faith in humanity but
it but it is important to talk about the
concept because that's the only way
people do change by the way is well
that's happened with me is when those
ideas are challenged in a way that tries
and it's difficult we're all human
beings we all have emotions
we all have egos but in a way to
challenge those ideas without making
about the ego because but actually just
really making about the concepts
themselves and so what you've referred
to is what I've come to refer to as
their aggressive left and and then what
I mean by the regressing left is because
they're you know not all people on the
left wing are regressive leftists are
just like not all Muslims are Islamists
and so what I mean by the regressive
left Arthur is this phenomenon of people
on the left wing of the debate who who
see between their duty their ideological
duty to challenge foreign policy
mistakes American and British foreign
policy mistake so what they interpret as
colonialism and neo neo clone
neoconservatism they see it as their
duty to challenge this and then they see
another challenge which is theocracies
and and you know the Islamist ideology
and they they have come to the they've
come to the to the view that you can't
challenge both of these together because
if you want to challenge Islamist
theocracy you're you're supporting
neoconservative foreign policy so they
in their minds they prioritized they've
said you know neoconservative foreign
policy the bigger evil organized
violence and chaos in the form of
military invasions is worse than
randomized non-state actor violence and
chaos so we're going to go after they
believe they're engaged in a war we're
going to go after the this is their
mindset we're going to go after the
organized violence and the reason why
sometimes you see duplicity in their
statements is because they genuinely
believe it's an ideological war and so
it's necessary to even engage in
propaganda to defeat this bigger evil
that we believe in which is the
organized violence of war now and so why
are call them regressive is because in
doing
they make alliances with some of the
most regressive yeah theocratic fascist
totalitarian barbaric murdering and
justifies of murderous regimes across
the world right so you know whether it's
Hezbollah a terrorist organization
that's currently fighting alongside the
dictator are certain to fight with
against the Syrian people and the reason
I use the example of his bomb are
because the man has just been elected to
the Labor Party leadership in the United
Kingdom who's uh who's actually born on
this regressive left phenomenon as has
been historically has been very close to
groups such as supporters of groups such
as Hezbollah and that's why I'm citing
this example so whether it's Hezbollah
or whether it's Hamas you know on the
one hand I can see the frustration of
people who want a two-state solution
sure which includes a secure free and
independent Israel and a secure and free
and independent Palestine but that
frustration shouldn't legitimize ah the
supporting an organization that has at
the heart of its policy the
legitimization of targeting civilians
and so what's happened is why I call
them regressive is that they've allied
in their anti colonial prioritization
with some of the most regressive
theocratic organizations that are out
there in the world yeah and then and
then and then they fear they feel that
anyone who who criticizes those
organizations is by definition with the
neoconservative so they must attack them
and that's what's going on and I take
the view actually you can criticize I I
opposed the Iraq war and the invasion of
Iraq from my jail cell
Egypt I have never supported the
invasion of Iraq I've never supported me
or conservativism and a member of a
Liberal Democrats in the UK I've never
been a member of any conservative party
I've never been a conservative or
supporter of wars in that sense in my
life so so you can oppose those things
at the same time you can oppose three
aquatic fascism you know we can have two
thoughts at the same time and it's not
impossible to do and I encourage
everyone to try it yeah I love how you
wrap that together because you're right
it's two thoughts at the same time and
when I talked about this with Sam you
know he was saying that they want to
find this nugget
you and once they find this thing that
they say you have not that you say you
have it but that they say you have then
it somehow discounts every other liberal
principle that you have which is why
suddenly I'm hearing from them that
they'll call Bill Maher is suddenly a
neocon Bill Maher who has I think stood
for every liberal principle been against
every war that I can possibly think of
and I have a suspicion that
unfortunately what these guys are doing
I think for the reasons that you laid
out very well I think they're actually
strengthening the extremists on both
sides right because they're
strengthening the Islamist extremists
because they're not challenging them and
then they're strengthening the the
secular extremists because they're
saying they're making it seem like
there's this one set of ideas that can't
be talked about and secular people want
to talk about all ideas right well if
you if we come to refers to this as the
the Voldemort effect you know it's the
it's the the Harry Potter books in which
I'm Jay making devices really clever
mechanism but people in the story are so
fearful of the evil Voldemort the two
things happen one they can't they don't
wreck their don't believe Voldemort is
actually alive they think he's dead and
they refuse to admit accept anyone
that's telling them the voter what still
lives and the second is that they're so
petrified of this photo of who they
believe is dead
that they can't even name him so they
refer to him as he who must not be named
so that's what I mean is that the
vulnerable effect and that leads to you
know when you can't name something that
actually is staring you at you in the
face and you're so scared of it but you
deny exists and you don't want to name
it um
that increases the hysteria so you know
when present that says we must defeat
the evil ideology
well achievable ideology right you know
and and so then the average dude that
stands up in Donald Trump's rant rally
and says when are we going to deal with
America's Muslim problem or Carson who
says you know he doesn't want a Muslim
president when they say these things
because the evil ideology when they hear
that word what they mean by that is
Islam and by default every Muslim who
identifies with Islam yeah
which is why they don't want a Muslim
president so what we're doing is by
blurring those lines we're increasing
the hysteria and actually the fit and
the bigotry that we're trying to avoid
so what I argue is for those two reasons
and actually more importantly to empower
reforming Muslim voices within Muslim
communities because the first victims of
theocratic fascism will be those Muslims
themselves it'll be the Muslim women it
will be the minorities of the LEAs edie
women it will be the Coptic Christians
in Egypt it will be the liberal Muslims
you'll be the apostates the X Muslims it
will be the gay Muslims and the lesbian
Muslims these are the ones who first
suffer nor under the yoke of the aquatic
fascism we need to also provide them
with a lexicon that they can deploy in
their own internal reform debates so if
you don't if you don't recognize
Islamism what are they going to say is
the problem when they're having these
debates within their communities Islam
the religion that's gonna get them
killed immediately in the first place
aside from the you know the intellectual
point that what do you mean by slamming
religion it's interpreted in a million
different ways god damn that that's such
a good handle on why this is so
difficult because we're talking about
ideas we're talking about people we're
talking about religion we're talking
about a political movements it's just so
much at once so just to sort of read
just to bring around this this part of
it in terms of dealing with these people
the people that have been writing all
these things and all that how how
personally exhausting is it for you
because I see and I've read you know
where Sam has said you know he's not
going to do this anymore and he said to
me even that then suddenly it's like he
has to say something because it's not
fun being lied about or slandered or
smeared and and as I said before you in
a way get it worse a tweet by one of
these guys just this week to you was
about how he's going to report you to
the Department of Homeland Security when
you come to the United States because he
doesn't want an X terrorist here I mean
this is really horrible stuff how do you
just deal with it on the personal level
it's exhausting right you see the the
the thing with this tweet is it really
raises an interesting insight and again
you know I hope this guy really you know
changes his approach to this but um the
interesting thing this raises is is a
liberal guy who ostensibly opposes
profiling at airports okay which by the
way I've always done
I've always been I'm not
you can find more that I've done against
profiling than any of these voices if
you google google maids on YouTube
there's a whole debate I've had on BBC
Newsnight which is the flagship news
show in the UK against the left wings
Labour Party member of Parliament's who
also happens to Muslim who was
advocating profiling five years ago and
I was debating you on that saying you
know this is a silly idea so I've always
been against profiling but so was this
guy who send the tweet you just refer
yeah yeah what's what's interesting is
suddenly when somebody is breaking out
of the group think think
and dis associating themselves with the
tribal identity that you that we use to
to have this us in them kind of game
that we refer to earlier that you know
you're either with Aamir Khan's or
you're with us and that kind of us and
them relies on this tribal identity when
someone breaks free from that tribal
identity refuses to the long here or
there some you find it's open season
that all the principles that we use to
actually tarnish the neocons I would
said neo-cons who want to profile
Muslims it's the neo cons were racist
we're using that same racism against
those dissenting voices I was called a
porch monkey right I was called a native
informant I was called a house Muslim by
white non-muslims in this instance
absolutely reputable people this isn't
just random eggs on Twitter sayings its
no no no these are these are journalists
that work for established organizations
at the right for established blogs and
then on top of that you've just
mentioned somebody saying I hope DHS
reads the department moment that's
guillotine reads your book before you
come to the States because I don't want
a next terrorist coming into the into
the United States and you know I put
aside the fact I was never a terrorist
that's advocating profiling by somebody
who literally a day earlier had been on
CNN accusing Sam Harris of advocating
profiling yeah and so it's suddenly what
happens is when you break away from that
group kind of tribal group think it
becomes open season and that's why I
said earlier that I think what's going
on here is they genuinely believe
they're engaged in the war and so in a
war all of these tactics become
legitimate because the objective is to
win it's not to find the truth and I
think that's part of the
problem that's why I think this dialogue
and this conversation is so important
yes because what we do is we break down
that hostility so I keep referring
that's why actually it's a lesson to
myself as well it's so important to
remain polite with these guys because
whatever they say to me if I if I
reinforce their their notion that
they've somehow managed to convince
themselves of that that this is a war
and if I respond in that manner they
will double down and they will continue
to ask this is a war and that anything
is is is permissible yeah so you know
that's why I try and deescalate it and I
fail sometimes but I you know it's
important for me to keep trying yeah I
feel the same way I try as well from the
little piece of this that I'm part of
and I've tried to engage some of these
people in a respectful way and
unfortunately you know as Sam is
Illustrated quite well it's hard to
debate when you have your facts and then
the person you're debating is debating
what they think you say or what they
want you to say not not what you what
you actually say you know I think a
little bit of this also is what Bill
Maher refers to as the the bigotry or
the soft bigotry of low expectations do
you feel that that somehow these people
and again I'm talking about the white
liberals in this group that they think
because you think differently than they
want you to think like oh that shows
racism right Thank You Theresa
you could cut right now into your show
um when you when you do your production
yeah an image of me stalking me talking
to Sam Harris and I'm being called a
porch monkey for it yeah and me talking
to Morgan Freeman now now the question I
ask is why why would none of these guys
and they haven't dancers why would any
of these guys not call me a porch monkey
for talking to Morgan Freeman not call
me his native informant not call me his
porch monkey yet when I'm talking to a
white man mm-hmm
Peggy's porch monkey they call me his
native informants that's the racism of
low expectations it's the assumption
that when a brown man is talking to a
brown man it's a meeting of equals but
when a brown man is talking to a white
land that brown man suddenly loses all
agency and can't think for himself and
is following the white man's thoughts
and yet the irony is that I don't even
use that form of identity politics to
describe people I don't see people as
white people brown people I see pits
detective
I use I I like people to look at people
as their values you know as liberal if
someone's Islamist if someone's you know
conservative that's how I look at people
um it tells me where I stand with them
much more than skin color does but these
are the people who are who are
ostensibly anti-racist deploying that
form of racism and you'll find that you
know I tweeted an image of Morgan
Freeman in these yesterday and put it on
my facebook page I have not once heard
any reaction from any of this
progressive left phenomenon in the sense
of being called his native informant or
his house Muslim or his porch monkey it
hasn't simply hasn't happened that there
is a best example of the reverse racism
of no expectations you just referred to
yeah so I have been using the term
regressive left also I just started
using it in the last few weeks and a few
of my my friends that are in this space
aren't thrilled with me because of it
but I think what you're exposing there
is a fatal flaw of progressivism because
they view things in the prism of
identity politics it's very hard to
extricate someone with a separate idea
or someone that doesn't fit the the
cliche and you're literally a walking
breathing example of that which is
explains why you get the the [ __ ] that
you do and it's important to mention at
the same time when I'm sitting there I
tweet out that I um I was made Morgan
Freeman in the mosque explaining you
know having a conversation about the
difference between Islam is live isn't
it is important to mention that at the
same time I got lots of reaction from
people saying the difference between
Islam and Islamism is in your head and
actually you know they're the same thing
so there's also that that side of the
reaction you know I get it from that
side to people insisting that Islam is
what they believe it to be which is what
I was kind of an elite and that I'm just
engaged myself in a form of apology err
for what Islam is and so it's it's it's
difficult to try and strike this balance
where you know we need honesty in this
conversation we need people to accept
that there's a problem with Islamist
extremism and there's also in fact a
challenge in dealing with taking Islam
out of its medieval heyday the paradigms
the theological paradigms that were
developed in the medieval era that we
simply haven't moved on from yeah
and actually that means that a whole
bunch of Muslims so the Islamic service
you don't write me a whole bunch of
traditionalist non-islamist conservative
Muslims don't like me because I talked
about reforming the interpretation and
then a whole bunch of anti-muslim people
on the other side who want me to a pasta
sites don't like me because because I
say Aslam can be interpreted and they
want me to say that Islam is evil so you
know you end up getting kind of stuck in
this middle this it requires a lot of
patience yeah well I guess if you have a
lot of people hating you you might be
telling the truth
how about yeah you don't need to be a
believer in Islam to concede the point
which is the point I was making with Sam
who I think has since shifted in his
view and is accepting that he's Venus
changed somewhat on this point you don't
need to be a believer in the religion of
Islam to concede that texts can be
interpreted it's not as simple as saying
I'm gonna go to a restaurant and order a
lobster and if you bring me a chicken
why did you bring the chicken when I
ordered a lobster because it's the menu
says Lobster you're ordering one thing
there what we're talking about is a
manual a bit like a car manual when
something's gone wrong in the engine and
reading the whole thing and working out
what the diagnosis is you know where the
particular relevant parts are how you
put them together when you're talking
about complex ideas like that like
interpreting Scripture and adapting them
to the time and space we find ourselves
in you know by definition it's an
exercise in interpretation and that's
why even with the US Constitution you've
got the same document being used as a
source for pro-choice and pro-life
people or pro-gun laws and and and gun
restriction people using the very same
document to make their arguments because
the dispute is over what the document
means in this day and age in the first
place and so you don't really need to
believe in the scripture to concede that
there is no one definitive reading of
Shakespeare there's no one definitive
reading of the Bible and there's no one
definitive reading of the Koran yeah all
right so one more piece on this portion
of all this what do you make of the term
islamaphobe because to me the term
itself has a lot of problems with it
because I don't think people fear Islam
as in the religion they fear if there if
there is a fear for some people it's the
actions they fear the actions that
people are taking in the name of the
religion and again that I know that can
be confusing for people because that's
the
eeeh verse the people but I do see this
meme of calling everyone in Islamophobia
and it goes of course to a lot of things
we've talked about so far but I fear
that their use of that word also is
creating a real a real backlash to what
they want to accomplish well they see
often this word is deployed to silence
you know it's used to kind of muzzle the
debate when people have every right to
criticize and scrutinize and saturn's
any idea whether it's Christianity is
science whether it's religion whether
it's Islam any idea is open to scrutiny
in fact that's the the essence of
progress it's how our societies have
ended up where they are today and every
innovator for their day was a blasphemer
yes Galileo questioned things that he
was called a heretic for I was
considered a heretic for the theory of
evolution and so you know and even
prophets were heretics against the old
religion you know whether that's
Mohammed Jesus almost so at the end of
the day if it wasn't for blasphemy if it
wasn't for in other words questioning
established norms and heresy we wouldn't
have progress so to use the word
Islamophobia to silence any scrutiny of
an idea would be to hinder this debate
and the progress that is needed in this
debate I don't like the terms of that
reason and I think it's deployed too
often against people who are simply
questioning whether you know whether
Islam needs to be reformed or not or
whether Islamism has a relationship to
Islam which of course it does um you
know Islamism is an offshoot of Islam
it's wrong to say it's got nothing to do
with Islam and so people that have been
asking these questions to deal with some
very real problems in the world are
being called Islamophobes that's
actually unfair I'd prefer the word
anti-muslim bigoted there is such a
thing as anti-muslim bigotry there are
absolute there are people who like
Carson who don't believe in he perhaps
don't even easily volution but they also
don't want Muslim presidents of the
United States what do you do with the
neuroscientist who doesn't believe in
evolution those things don't seem like
they should add up but it kind of
indicates you know there is something
about people that have they want to
discriminate against people like me
because of the religion I was born into
as that that's that's anti-muslim
bigotry but as very different to
scrutinize
Islam the idea and that's why I
developed this Maxim which again the
dialogue with Sam and that is that no
idea should be or is ever above scrutiny
no idea is above screws and you know
people are beneath dignity and I think
that really nicely summarizes whether we
should stand on this debate yeah that's
actually a great segue for my next
question which is what has the the
reaction from just sort of the
mainstream Muslim community in England
been to you because when I even when I
tweeted out that we were going to sit
down and do this the majority of it was
positive now obviously we have a certain
amount of people that follow both of us
and know what we think about things that
enjoy what we do so that's expected but
I did get some people that said oh you
know it was it was this porch monkey
mentally oh he's just doing this for for
money and affection of white people and
a lot of that what I think is pure
nonsense but what what about the
mainstream Muslim community that you're
around every day well look you know
mainstream Muslims aren't Islamists they
are conservative but they're not
Islamists and it's certainly not
jihadist ah and so what they're not
going to do even if they disagree with
me is they're not gonna you know they're
not going to basically attack me for it
uh or or launched into a tirade of ad
hominem even if they disagree now I'm
very realistic about where I stand among
my own religious communities that's
because if I had just was treated myself
to challenging Islamism I probably would
have had the support of the overwhelming
majority the mainstream of Muslims but
the other whelming mainstream also
happened to be in social and religious
matters conservative with a small seat
and I challenge that too I call for
reform in our approach and
interpretation of the scripture I am a
liberal socially as well as politically
and and I've mentioned I'm a member of
the Liberal Democrats in the United
Kingdom which is the centrist party
there and so you know I have very openly
supported a lot of social reform on
these issues and I think that you know
we have the autosum arsenic William who
advocated for the reconciliation of
evolution with Islamic Crete the Islamic
Creed that was incredibly controversial
when he did so he was kicked out of his
mosque for that and that's not an
Islamist mosque it's a
other tip mosque and so the reason that
that you will sense a lot of backlash
it's because we take on the twin
challenges of wanting to again another
sort of maxim is that it you know what
we want to do is that Islamism must be
intellectually terminated whereas Islam
needs to be reformed but that's the twin
challenge that faces us and it means
that obviously because no change is
seamless all change is painful a lot of
people get upset when they come here
some of the things we say but that's the
nature of change I mean you know that's
how societies change it's it's it's it's
normal yeah I know you might be slightly
hesitant to talk about this but can I
ask you just in terms of your own
personal safety I'm sure you are you are
threatened I know that that a lot of the
other people in this space from bill to
Sam to many others have a certain amount
of threatened that they deal with from
from all fronts by the way you know I
think from someone like Sam it comes
from people from radical Christians too
so I don't I don't even want to make
this about Islam or Muslims particularly
but people I think need to understand
that you put yourself at great risk to
talk about the things that you're
talking about right yeah I mean I don't
want to dwell on this but yeah it's not
exactly the safest occupation in the
world so there's a lot going on in in
England politically right now in Jeremy
Corbyn who you mentioned earlier is now
head of the Labour Party what's the
general sense of the political
atmosphere in England right now because
in America we get very very little even
if I just flick on BBC for a second I
mean we got very very little of what's
going on with with basically our biggest
ally in the world yeah it's interesting
because we are facing the inverse of
what's happening here with the
phenomenon of the rise of Donald Trump
we've got Jeremy Corbyn who is populist
in the way that Trump is are on the
left-wing of politics yeah um and it's
the same discourse and actually that's
why you have the horse horse shoe theory
of politics you know that actually
ultimately you hear left and right they
come and they end up when they go to the
extremes meeting in the middle anyway
yeah um Mussolini's fascist and I'm not
calling calling a fascist by any means
but Rossellini's fascism was a left-wing
phenomena and then emerged into
totalitarian fascism so they end up
meeting and the reason
that so if you look at Corbin and Trump
what they both have in common is their
anti-establishment approach is their
total disdain for politics in the ways
that things have been going on they want
to change the status quo they're playing
on popular anger which in many instances
is there for legitimate reasons but in
other instances it's playing up the
identity politics they identify the
other so in Trump's case the Mexicans
and the wall at the city idea of
building a wall that you want um you
know identifying the other and a lying
with some unsavory people to achieve
that it's all part of parcel of of the
politics of our times and across Europe
were witnessing this phenomena the rise
of far-right populist parties and in
Greece we had Golden Dawn now in Casa
series syriza which is a far left
populist party and in Scotland we had
the Scottish nationalists who wanted to
break away from the United Kingdom and
the other for them were the English so
because for whatever reason people are
feeling particularly vulnerable and
insecure they are rallying around
identity politics and defining
themselves against somebody else and I
think that's a particularly it's a very
unhelpful unhealthy way to engage in
politics and it leads to more decision
which is what we see playing out across
a lot yeah not only do we see it playing
out across the world but now you know we
have this massive refugee crisis which
you guys in Europe are having to deal
with much more than we are in the states
now Europe already has a huge problem
with integrating their immigrants as a
general rule especially in Muslim
communities right so what do you make of
what England or what the rest of the EU
should be doing or can be doing with the
refugee situation I think the important
thing is integration I would caution
people in the world be you know in the
United Kingdom we are overdue an Isis
attack so not if but when Isis chooses
and decides it's capable striking in the
UK I would urge people not to blame the
refugees these are people who are in
some cases who have fought Isis in Syria
and Iraq and are fled since then or in
other cases were fleeing for their lives
because they disagree with everything
that Isis is doing of course you know
among them there may be one or two
fighters and
but that's neither here nor there
because 1,000 born and raised British
citizens have gone to join Isis anyway
so they're finding easy enough to
recruit from UK born citizens know about
having to sneak them in with refugees so
if there are attacks a large people not
to blame these poor desperate refugees
who need our help and our sympathy and
our understanding and what I would
consider what I would say is important
to consider for governments on the other
hand is not repeat affair negatives when
what you mentioned integration wasn't
seen as important and so what we ended
up developing in Europe and in Britain I
can speak to one of these self
segregated communities that didn't mix
with one another and they grew up you
know it's possible in 2015 to be born
and raised in London as a Muslim
teenager and not have a single non
Muslim friend not a single friend from
the opposite sex and I just think that's
not a healthy psychological state to be
in so I would encourage governments to
have really really robust and strong
integration policies yeah do you think
that that's even possible because
they're already dealing with the
integration problem that exists it seems
to me that the conversation has been
dumbed down to the point where if you
say anything if you were to say well we
shouldn't bring in more refugees right
now
that people would immediately call you
racist which the truth probably is
somewhere between you know there's
obviously a certain amount of people are
going to be xenophobic no matter what
and then there are also some legitimate
concerns about what the what this can do
to societies but we so rarely have this
conversation right yeah and it's you
know at the end of the day the
immigration conversation is a bit like
these lenders in conversation that it's
immediately shut down and accusations of
bigotry are the first you know recourse
if you like of those who want to shut
that conversation down it is important
that these conversations are in fact
thrown open in the recent history the
political history of the United Kingdom
we've seen the consequences of not
having these conversations because when
these debates were shut down by the the
mainstream parties what happened as a
result is the rise of two groups one a
street protest movement and the other a
political party the UK United Kingdom
Independence Party they wants to break
away from the European
was the end-all immigration that party
which which started taking chunks out of
the conservative support base that arose
at lightning speed in the UK headed by
Nigel Farage precisely because the main
political parties didn't want to talk
about racism and so an uglier version of
that conversation happened on the
outside on the fringes of the mainstream
because we didn't want to talk about it
and the other thing that happened was
the rise of the English Defence League
the EDL so what have been Europe's
largest street protest movement began
organizing rallies and demonstrations up
and down the country because
conversation about Islamism so what I
advocate the reason why I'm so so so
heavily for having these conversations
is we don't have them in the mainstream
in a responsible way the fringes will
have them in an irresponsible way and
that's the danger of the Voldemort
effect but I refer to ya and that's very
much what I'm trying to do with this
show which is why I'm gonna have people
from all over the political spectrum
here because we need we need these
conversation so just one more thing on
the refugee thing what do you make of
the Arab countries that basically aren't
taking in their brothers I mean I think
Saudi Arabia has let in maybe 30
families or something all these
countries were seeing Egypt's not
letting anyone in Turkey has done a lot
Turkey's not in our country but all but
all these countries that are doing this
what do you make of that so we go to
caveat here's the Gulf Arab countries
that have let in zero refugees whereas
Jordans
Lebanon and these surrounding countries
that aren't Gulf Arabs have millions you
know of refugees and so there is that
distinction to be made Jordan is
overflowing with refugee camps and tents
in the Saudis Lebanon yeah but the Gulf
Arabs you know the Emirates Saudi Arabia
these countries Kuwait they they they
think that actually they think that
their responsibilities have been met
simply by providing funds to the refugee
camps and I think that's a particularly
interesting point there to look at as to
the art just with it like just as with a
Syria conflict there are certain
responsibilities the regional powers
have to deal with conflict in their own
back gardens and in their own region and
unfortunately that has
lene happening on the one hand we
complain when the international
community led by the United States of
America intervenes and you're on the
other hand when when no intervention is
forthcoming we complain because we're
saying that no one cares about all the
women and children and innocent men who
are dying and actually that the only way
around this is to say okay if you don't
want international intervention then
take responsibility for your own regions
and and intervene yourselves and that
applies to refugees and it applies to
the war in Syria and dealing with that
through political and diplomatic and
military needs and I'm you know I'm very
critical unfortunately I don't think
these Gulf countries have been doing
even nearly enough yes record and by the
way I don't want to just blame the Gulf
countries or any of the Arab states
because we just saw at the UN in these
last couple days there seems to be now
be this new alliance between Iraq and
Iran and Russia and again as to what you
just said the more the u.s. pulls out it
seems the worse it gets and every time
we go in we seem to make it worse so
there are no easy answers here I think
is the is the ultimate conclusion so I
have one more thing for you
because I've been trying to end all my
interviews on on some sort of feeling of
hope and actually you've done a nice job
of giving us some hope this whole way
through but I really sense that there
has been over the last couple months
a real secular awakening I sense it in
in the response I'm getting to the
videos the Facebook messages people
trying to me emails the tweets the whole
thing that people that secular people
that want to base their values on
humanism and not on you know magical sky
gods and all of that stuff that they're
really waking up and I think you've had
a part to do with it I think Sam I think
many other people do you sense that -
please tell me you do or I'm in a lot of
trouble
I sense particularly that more what
voices that I call the minorities within
the minority
you know people on the left that we've
spoken about earlier they traditionally
care about the minority communities but
actually I'd say to them that if they
really worth their salt if they really
want to test their mettle what they
should be carrying about are the
minorities within those minority
communities the gamers limbs the lesbian
Muslims the X Muslims the the liberal
Muslim voices the feminist Muslims and
the minorities such as the Christians in
Egypt of the CDs in Iraq
so those minorities within minority
communities I sense have been rallying
and waking up in galvanizing I think I
sense more and more Muslim voices coming
out to speak against not just Islamism
but also Islamic religious conservative
ISM and we get messages every single day
we are people asking to join our
organization to help us to work with us
and I think that's really it's fantastic
because if if we're going to really
defeat the scourge of theocratic fascism
and if we're going to help reform the
way in which Islam is interpreted today
and those voices are really the crucial
voices that we need to hear for yeah
well you've been a huge part of that so
I thank you for taking some time well
while you're in New York your book with
Sam Islam in the future of Tolerance has
already sold out the pre-orders already
sold out on Amazon it's coming out way
it's coming out in a couple days in the
bookstores right yeah it will hit the
bookstores very soon and then everyone
hoping be able to get a copy and then
actually after that the Kindle version
will come out too
there is a Kindle version coming out but
it'll come out after the compact
hardback version hits the bookshelves
all right well I'm really glad that we
got a chance to do this almost face to
face we concede you but one day we'll be
able to have a beer and do it for real
and good luck with with all your work
appreciate it thank you